gérard dit moi je trouve la polémique un
peu obscène ce sont les mêmes qui en
tête de gondole vont dire que les
[ __ ] c'est pas bien pascal a qui
font ça pour leur propre pub bassin
certaines affairés fait comme le di
francesca s'il est bien la cause
si on a qui disent et qui donne de
l'argent à cette maison qui va sourire
en 2021 qui va accueillir jusqu'à 400
patients par année ça change voilà moi
je trouve que c'est très positif
et c'est très important mais j'ai rien
dit je serai plus à l'aise il est jeune
on aurait alors jean pascal roux dit ce
que vous avez dit vendredi qu est ce que
vous avez dit vendredi qui a fait qu'à
créer polémique j'ai dit que tf1 allait
diffuser quelque chose qui me mettait
mal à l'aise pourquoi parce que pour moi
moi j'ai un rapport très compliqué mais
la mort c'est pour ça que je veux pas
voir le biopic sur une période et cdg
j'ai du mal avec la mort d'accord on ne
regarde pas pour ça vous n'avez pas
regardé la cage les critiques et grégory
où l'association
ou alors montré les images et ce qui
m'embête c'est que quand on fait quelque
chose pour une association je pense que
tf1 peut le faire ou on joue le jeu à
100% parce que y'a pas que grégory il ya
des centaines malheureusement il ya
plein de grosses qui sont malades
pleines de gens on reverse tout tf1
n'est pas donc oui enfin une coup et
disons qu'ils ont fait quelque chose sur
grégory et en reverse et c'est très bien
pour l'image de tf1
et c'est bien pour la recherche et
j'espère que c'est ce que vous ferez
vous ferez avec votre s'était déjà fait
soigner on sortait de prison
c est parce qu il ya votre album où je
vais finir je vais faire les dialysés
l'essonne a fini reçues et les droits
d'auteur tout vous réussit un petit
sekkaki la chanson tout mais c'était
chanson qui existait déjà
robert c'est super parce que le fond du
sujet là parce qu a pas de débat parce
que malgré vos vidéos autour mais tu
mettrais des hypocrites tu entends pas
ce que nous savons déjà peiné et ça a
peiné tout les gens qui soutient grégory
qui soutiennent l'association sûr tu
nous a plus vraiment de la peine requise
par les terminaux termine juste mes
propos pour moi une autre paire à tort
je termine juste mourir au pot pour nous
tu fait partie
même que tu le veuilles ou non de la
famille star académie c'est comme ici à
une famille tpm p on crache pas sur les
anciens
là tu sais que je vais cracher de rabat
mécano
nous fait du mal en fait parce que nous
on éternue on n'a rien contre toi tu
n'as pas le droit de dire qu'on est
hypocrite a pas le droit de dire qu'on
n'a pas le mien parce que grégory nous a
unis dans quelque chose on se bat pour
lui en donne tout alors évidemment dans
un monde parfait ce serait bien de tf1
qui redonne tout près sûr déjà ils vont
parler au moins de l'assaut alors alors
alors je vous remets toi sur ce coup là
je malaisie doit être fait je le droit
d'analyser mois le clip j'ai vu a le
droit d'avoir le deuil et bien sûr je
vais juste je veux juste finir comme je
vous écoute j'ai juste si vous en faites
pas vous m'écoutez juste j'ai regardé le
clip mois la manière dont s'est tournée
la manière dont ces films et alors je
suis pas une grande acteurs comme vous
le dites certes mais quand j'aurai
quelque chose qui me que je trouve je
repasserai david o ce que je trouve ces
voix là c'est ce côté un peu on se
retrouve on pleure si vous êtes vus
depuis laisse moi finir j ai pas parlé
en vo non mais tu allais le faire quand
vous vous êtes parler c'est la vie voir
pendant apparemment depuis 14 ans on
pleure en tissu ou il ya tout le temps
vous pleurez pas pourquoi vous l'avez
pas fait avant donc c'est juste ce côté
pour moi si pau creed est trop fort pour
vous j'espère que les termes comme l'anc
depuis tête où ça ne semble pas aussi
forte que je sais pas comment j'aurais
réagi parce que pour mot ce traité sur
ce coup là et on entend s'essayer aux
médias qu'il n'y a pas de débat
moi je parle vous savez ce que c'est
elle la finalité tout ça c'est les dons
mais je suis très heureux en tout cas tu
ne te ra dickey de la lumière des
menteurs montré heureux qu'ils aient eu
de la lumière faite sur votre album ça
va pousser les ventes mais je n'aime pas
l'initiative de tout ça donc il y aura
des dons pour l'association et c'est ça
le fond de l'histoire alors